pour parler de cette rentrée politique
en france et du positionnement ou des
tentatives un poteau de positionnement
des différents partis nous sommes avec
alexis poulain éditorialistes et notre
nouvelle rubrique l'édito bonsoir alexis
poulain ravi de vous retrouver pour
cette première yes dm ce soir la rentrée
des partis politiques on les a vu
défiler avec différentes état d'esprit
évidemment l air la république en marche
et rennes de nombreuses universités
d'été ce week-end et on commence avec
eux un petit coup d'oeil à gauche oui à
gauche avec cette rentrée en ordre
dispersé 1 il ya eu le parti socialiste
et levée la france insoumise et puis les
figures tutélaires qui reviennent
françois hollande toujours là laurent
joffrin qui veut lancer un mouvement
d'idées et lionel jospin qui bien sûr un
livret dit que finalement emmanuel
macron ne s'est pas ancrée dans
l'histoire il n'a été qu'un moment et
qui porte un jugement assez dur sur le
parti socialiste qui n'est plus à même
de rassembler autour d'un projet projet
que bien jean-luc mélenchon compte bien
poursuivre puisque lui a dit que j'ai au
moins lionel jospin et dans le dialogue
et pour le leader de la france insoumise
il entend lui au contraire fédérer le
peuple ait lancé un mouvement d'une
nouvelle génération autour de son projet
donc vraiment on est on est dans un
moment politique où la gauche a bien du
mal à se trouver qui pourra être le
pivot central peut-être d'un candidat
d'unités pour 2022 le cas c'est une
majorité d'adhésion qu'il faut
construire
si je suis candidat j'arriverai fort de
mon bilan électoral de mon expertise
muni d'un programme ouvert d'une
brillante équipe soudée idéologiquement
est décidé à fonder avec ceux qui
l'auront voulu une nouvelle force
politique
cette force sera celle de la génération
suivante voilà ça c'est l interview de
l'ops dans lequel vont se pare de
jean-luc mélenchon
dérouler un peu ses idées alors à droite
alexis visiblement la stratégie de 2022
et est loin d'être claire là encore à
droite c'est plus compliqué il y avait
ce week end un rassemblement de jeunes
plus de nombreux jeunes qui étaient
autour de gérard larcher et des grands
pontes de la droite françois baroin
jette l éponge il n'a jamais vraiment
pris le lead mais il y avait cette idée
d'une candidature possible à la
candidature de françois baroin ce ne
sera pas le cas mais c'est christian
estrosi qui jette le trouble dans les
troupes de la droite en pensant
peut-être que la droite devrait faire
des manuels macron son candidat et se
rallier eh bien ce n'est pas du tout de
la vie de gérard larcher qui répondait
lors d'une matinale à une radio on
écoute je pense qu'il ya un espace c'est
le sens de mon combat
on ne peut pas se réduire un choix
binaire ou ignorer qu emmanuel macron où
marine le pen il ya un espace politique
pour la droite et le centre
je veux que les français aient le choix
voilà pourquoi je me bats pour cet
espace politique et surtout pour la
liberté de choix des français
certains voudraient nous faire croire qu
emmanuel macron serai un président de
droite pour une politique de droite
cette politique qui est conduite n'est
pas la nôtre
mais voilà pour la réaction de gérard
larcher la gauche la droite et le centre
alors le centre c'est encore une autre
histoire
katia technique en parlait à l'assemblée
nationale une hémorragie de députés
marcheurs la république en marche qui
attend toujours son nouveau leader à
l'assemblée et qui perd encore et
toujours et bien des députés cette fois
ci ils rejoignent les rangs du modem et
le modem et bien on peut dire que ce
parti a le vent en poupe avec françois
bayrou nommé au plan et qui grossit ses
rangs à l'assemblée nationale ça pose
question sur l'avenir de la république
en marche puisque comme lionel jospin le
disait emmanuel macron a du mal à
centrer à s'ancrer dans l'histoire reste
à savoir si le projet la république en
marche peut durer après l'échec aux
municipales est ce que les sénatoriales
vont changer la donne est ce qu'il y
aura des candidats marcheurs sous
l'étiquette la république en marche ou
bien est ce que c'est le modem qui va
être fait heure de roi la question reste
entière mais à voir la façon dont
françois bayrou revient
le jeu politique en au premier plan avec
ce rôle dans la planification vient et
on peut se demander comment va se faire
une coalition même si tout cela reste
dans une majorité présidentielle
derrière emmanuel macron moins soudé
qu'avant avec des groupes dissidents on
est loin bien sûr des frondeurs du ps
mais quand même il se passe quelque
chose d'à la république en marche et ce
n'est pas forcément du bon côté du moins
pour le groupe alors alexis enfin un mot
sur le thème de la sécurité il est
évidemment sur toutes les lèvres en
cette rentrée politique est ce que ce
sera l'un des grands enjeux de la
présidentielle
c'est du moins le jeu du moment
porté par gérald darmanin qui va
dérouler son plan demain et c'est
surtout bien sûr celui de marine le pen
qui tenait son université d'été et qui
en a fait un thème majeur comme toujours
d'ailleurs avec le front national reste
à savoir quelles vont être les moyens
pour ce plan sécurité et qu'elle peut
être aussi les moyens du rassemblement
national qui peine aujourd'hui à
recruter et bien des nouvelles recrues
et qui a fait une sorte de purge avec
les proches de marion maréchal-le pen
qui ont été mis un peu plus loin que de
la direction donc la sécurité oui c'est
le thème du moment est ce que ce thème
qui est cher à tous les français qui
réclament davantage de protection et de
sécurité va durer dans le temps jusqu'à
2022 ou bien est ce que gérald darmanin
va résoudre le problème rapidement avec
marlène schiappa bien ça reste à voir on
le verra dans les prochaines semaines
les prochains moins et de demain avec la
présentation de ce plan sécurité et puis
et puis voir si d'autres thèmes vont
bien sûr arriver d'ici la fin d'année la
crise sanitaire bien sûr le bilan des
modèles macron mais chaque partie
aujourd'hui à un problème et ce problème
c'est les idées et le programme et il ya
encore du temps bien sûr mais les idées
sont au coeur du débat et du pain sur la
planche pour tous ces partis merci
alexis poulain merci d'avoir été avec
nous